alors elle donne des leçons tout le
monde hein c'est ce que tout le monde me
dit là il paraît qu'elle devrait pas en
plus que c'est un petit peu compliqué
pour elle oui elle a voté pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon les amis de je crois pas c'est
une copine de Mélenchon alors elle pour
moi c'est c'est le son par excellence je
vais laisser Géraldine d'abord parler
parce que j'ai pas entendu j'aime bien
entendre Géraldine parce que là je suis
avec Jordan de luxe au bout de ma vie
c'est dommage c'est que moi elle me fait
beaucoup rire et je trouve que c'est le
spectacle sont brillants et qu'elle aime
aussi
voilà je trouve que c'est incroyable
mais malheureusement je trouve que quand
elle parle en tant que citoyenne elle a
une sorte de posture qui est une
imposture je trouve que voilà elle est
dans une sorte de démagogie de leçon qui
est insupportable jusqu'au bout de son
système il faut absolument plus que ces
livres soient vendus sur Amazon
ces vidéos soient vendues sur Amazon que
ces séries soient vendues sur Amazon à
ce moment-là on va les acheter on va on
va lui donner l'argent complètement du
système à ce moment-là et moi ce que
j'aurais trop bien qu'elle donne les
200000 € à une association qui l'aurait
peut-être
[Musique]
tu dois faire ou pas faire et par
ailleurs je trouve que pour les gens qui
achètent sur Amazon je trouve ça je
trouve que c'est leur dire bah vous
faites ce que vous faites c'est sale ce
que vous faites c'est pas bien vous êtes
des mauvais consommateurs et moi ce que
je fais c'est pur et puis Internet après
tous les comédiens bien sûr pour des
ventes moi je trouve qu'elle a
complètement merdé Amazon s'ils ont une
économie qui leur permet de prendre de
donner 200000 balles au comédien bah
tant mieux tant mieux aussi pour les
comédiens elle si on la suit c'est à
dire que en fait c'est elle quand elle
vend ses spectacles elles gagnent de
l'argent donc ça veut dire quoi et je
pense pas qu'elle gagne le SMIC donc
c'est n'importe quoi et encore une fois
c'est une mauvaise à cause des comédiens
il y a deux comédiennes Camille cotta et
Marion Cotillard qui devaient faire la
saison 4 elles sont en train de se
demander si elles vont le faire ou pas à
cause de cette polémique donc
franchement elle aurait mieux fait de se
taire sur ce coup-là